i was uh looking at rogan's instagram
joe rogan and uh he reposted this thing
from tim oliphant an artist who's an
incredible artist incredible artist of
elon joe and of chip flying the ship
that they're in the tesla ship spaceship
and but it made me very sad because what
tim was saying is that
i've drawn since i was a kid graduated
from college with an art degree a few
years later i found myself pursuing in a
miserable home improvement job mostly
painting houses but joe inspired him to
quit his home improvement job and become
a full-time artist and i was like uh
this is where our society is done to
people people don't want to do home
improvement work they don't want to be
plumbers they want to be artists and
this is a big problem
a functional job that is has great
benefit to society that is tangible and
people are like but i don't want to
service my community i want to draw
pictures i certainly respect art i make
art we make music but i think the issue
is not it may be unfair to target the
one guy who's actually a really good
artist you know what drawing pictures
isn't so bad it can be a useful way for
a person
he went on to clarify that he was he
didn't like working for a corporation
and being part of the cog and the
machine thing i get that yeah what were
you i was going to say
i find it remarkable that we're in this
this this uh we've developed to a point
where
complaining on the internet is more
valuable than building a house or fixing
someone's plumbing that's not a picture
absolutely because you can't have the
same number of people doing it like a
small minority of people are able to
become very successful doing something
like this but if it was equally as
valuable like we would have just as many
people in both trades making money but
like most people who try to make money
complaining on the internet totally fail
whereas i think if you go to trade
school you are pretty likely to make an
income it's fair point it's fair point i
just think you know ian you made a good
point we people should feel good about
doing yeah trades
and
i just think
when we're when we're kids or at least
when i was the millennial generation
we're told to be the greatest of all
time we're told to be rock stars and
race car drivers and astronauts well
yeah it's we have denigrated work so
much right there was this idea and
almost everyone was told this growing up
uh not me personally but so many people
i know have their parents tell them
things like you know if you don't uh
study hard and get that degree you're
going to end up in you know manual labor
or as a sanitary worker or something
like that
and for some people that's what they
want to do and thank goodness because
that's an extremely valuable
contribution yeah i should be very clear
about oliphant i've never talked to tim
oliphant before and he specified that he
didn't he he got offered his boss's job
at the at the home improvement and he
didn't want to climb the ladder and i
understand being part of a corporate
corporation and i get it but
you know what made me sad was just the
lack of desire or just the sociological
lack of desire to fix houses and more of
the people want to paint pictures
anytime you i mean i that's my personal
experience right like i was a big law
and and you might say well that's a
really prestigious professional job and
like i just looked around and realized
some of the cases i was working on like
okay this might not be like literally
working with my hands or something but i
am a cognitive litigation machine right
like i am representing a
trust created out of a bankruptcy of a
company that is suing
64 of these small issuers out of some
mortgage-backed securities and like
we're you know constructing these briefs
in order to extract whatever we can out
of these small little issuers to the
benefit of this bankruptcy trust which
you can literally go and buy shares and
and the only thing you know the only
thing that this trust owns is the rights
to the proceeds of the litigation you'll
always work for someone yeah there's no
difference between
being the employee of a company and
running your company now obviously there
are certain differences what i mean to
say is
i have to negotiate with people i work
with all day every day you know we've
got a bunch of people that are involved
in how this company works from the
infrastructure end of things to the ad
sales end of things and their
disagreements and there are term
deal terminations
now if you have a simple agreement with
another person i'll do this work for you
in exchange for this rate that's the
exact same thing we do that i do every
day as someone who owns the company
i just i think people need to get out of
the mindset of i'm a cog in a machine
working for someone no
you provide a service you negotiate with
company if companies not providing you
what you need you leave and negotiate
with someone else when i worked for vice
people were shocked that i quit when i
quit
and they were like why would you leave
vice is the best oh they're the greatest
and i was like
vice works for me and i work for them
when they stopped providing me with what
i needed i fired them
that that's the mentality i had i went
in there i said guys i want this this
and this
you got it okay i'm gonna do my thing i
will do my thing here you like that okay
great you gotta give me these things for
it i didn't just go and say i need a
paycheck i said i want these three
things delivered to me in exchange for
what you're going to get and i worked
for them as an employee and then once
they stopped delivering or didn't
provide i just said
i'm out i think of it as an employee
you're working for the corporation so is
the owner of the corporation you're both
working for the betterment of the
corporation and the owner primarily is
working for the people that are buying
his goods and services or her goods and
services the problem is when employees
don't have incentive to they don't gain
more if the company gains more and the
owner gains more so
that i understand feeling like a cog
because you're not getting an incentive
some work some work is just more
intellectually stimulating than other
work and interesting intrinsically like
i don't know there's
i can i can see how a guy would you know
want to be an artist and would get more
value and excitement out of doing art
and seeing it spread around the world
than they would out of
you know i think it's i think it's a mix
of cultural and
uh human nature
humans want social acceptance we want
other people to praise us and say we're
doing good things it works really well
on a small tribal scale when you are in
a village of 50 people and you do
something you come back with a huge bore
and everyone's clapping and cheering
because they're happy because they're
going to eat and you did this great
thing it feels really good i mean it's
how grooming works online in these
schools they keep trying to shower you
with love and make you feel good because
humans crave social acceptance because
we are social creatures
so what ends up happening is over time
you will get more praise for writing a
good song than you will
you know uh saving someone from a
burning building depending on the scale
of the burning building i suppose like
if you're a guy who's like in a plane
and you crash into the hudson river or
whatever you'll be here on the magazine
but how many firefighters are you know
walking the red carpet how many police
officers i just watched this crazy viral
video of a cop walks right up to to
arrest a guy and the guy just unloads on
him and then like it's brutal footage of
stuff this thing how often do we have no
cops are demonized to an insane degree
like i certainly have my complaints
about authoritarianism and what the
police department that can mean in terms
of certain circumstances but we demonize
the people who are working the
day-to-day jobs to make the system run
to save lives
you you'll get some 20-year-old
who will
spend
15 minutes writing a song and i
literally mean 15 minutes they'll be
like okay we got the beat we got the
hook we got the chorus send it over to a
company who then says we're gonna layer
get it done and then they're like put it
on tv for us and all of a sudden
everyone's screaming and crying and
clapping and cheering you are the
greatest
why would someone strive to be a
firefighter there was a poll
they asked young people what they what
they wanted to be when they grew up and
you know they all sat in america
influencers and you know the outside in
china
astronauts yep
so we have a cultural problem where our
culture praises
influencer because it's simple
virality is a machine in which we get
people addicted and it feels good to get
those numbers to see that that number
going up to see those views youtubers
have long talked about how when their
viewership goes down they get depressed
i can always tell you whenever you see
these youtuber burnouts where they're
like i just can't keep doing this
anymore look at their view count
it almost always is uh
preceded by their viewers like the last
five videos they made were lower than
normal and then all of a sudden they
have a breakdown because it feels like
you're losing and everybody hates you
and it's being ripped apart ripped away
from you meanwhile in china they're like
i really want to be an astronaut
we need to bring that back well in in
we in some ways we become more like the
things that we love and our culture has
lost sight of of what's really important
unfortunately well maybe and now now
some kudos to tim oliphant not only are
you one of the best artists i've ever
seen tim
uh
you're inspiring people to become
astronauts man this art we'll do that
yeah no i mean look art has utility and
this is coming from a guy who makes
cartoons which is you know by no means
high art and i'm very blessed i'm very
fortunate to be able to do what i do
everyone
who's on my crew who helps me is
absolutely fantastic and unbelievably
talented
but one of the biggest compliments that
i receive from people is from folks who
are just working regular nine to fives
you know important jobs construction
workers plumbers etc who will say things
like hey man your cartoon's bright in my
day i think that's awesome and i think
art can serve that purpose but very
often times what people want to do is
make it completely about themselves so
it's not about i want to enter i want to
entertain an audience it's about like i
want to get the praise i want to be the
cool person i want to be worshipped
basically and i think that temptation
sets in with anyone anytime they're in
front of any kind of audience
but what people have to keep sight of is
you're producing for other people and
that's true in any industry it doesn't
matter what you do and so part of the
reason i think our culture doesn't take
pride in its work is because we view it
as something which should just be about
ourselves and whether you become a
literal rock star musician or whether
you're building houses if you view what
you're doing as just being about you and
not for other people you're going to be
miserable well here yeah i'll simplify
it uh or i'll put my view very simply
for people i think most peop most of the
time if you are driven to become famous
and successful and you think i've had
people say this to me when i was working
for advice and traveling around they'd
say i really wish i could do what you
did i'd love to travel around the world
covering these stories
i know they're not serious i know what
they're really saying is
i want people watching me on on the
internet i want millions of views i want
the praise
because it's really easy to buy a plane
ticket to europe and walk around with
the cell phone
in fact
i you know when i went i went to spain
and covered a lot of protests well i
already own the cell phone so that
didn't cost me anything the plane ticket
was a couple hundred bucks i crashed you
know at a hostel for like 70 bucks you
know it was like 70 bucks for a couple
days and then i walked around filming
stuff
you can just do it if you want to do it
so
you know how do we get started on a show
like this well i wanted to do it i
didn't i there was when we started doing
the show we were getting you know like a
thousand people watching and i wasn't i
wasn't every day going like come on get
those numbers up get those i was just
like i like talking about these things
something changed in the dynamic of
artistry when people gain the ability to
control their own distribution channels
because radio basically in television
you gained rich artists that never
really existed in the past you'd have
people that were basically paid you'd
have they'd have a patron like leonardo
da vinci or whoever they might have some
money but it was usually like a very
wealthy landowner paying them money to
work and then they would be their patron
and then now all of a sudden we've got
rockstar tv star those didn't exist
until 100 years ago and it's messing
with people they think that it's a rich
scheme be an actor to get rich be a
musician together it's not about it was
never about the money people would play
music for dinner at night at a tavern
and hope that they got a place to stay
and that was the original you know i
mean there were orchestras
there were there were great works but it
really was like the wealthy being like
we like these things we wanted yeah but
there were residuals
is a new idea you would all you would
get paid for the night that you played
and that was it
and then they developed a recording and
now it's another another realm but there
there were famous musicians for a long
time yeah they would be famous but they
wouldn't always be rich that was the
weird thing until they could until they
could sell copies of their work right
once once we had um copyable media all
of a sudden albums could be sold and the
song could be performed everywhere all
at once and everyone would buy it up now
we have streaming and everyone's losing
money and piracy you see the age of i
don't like it's not actual pirate r but
it's like you know money um art
distribution copying and distributing it
illegally or or unethically um and and
it's like
it's almost like we're coming full
circle like we've passed through the age
of the rich artist and now we're going
back to like just be an artist if you
want to be an artist and do it in
addition to your other things that you
do you don't have to only just be an
artist all the time and you can we're
actually going back to sort of old
school patronage right like except
decentralized um you know you don't own
the i mean you don't necessarily say
that you own the rights to anything but
people will be like members to your show
and right have to you know patron you
know patronize you that way
um
i think it's
i mean and i think that's probably a
good thing i mean you know it it's not
as good for artists in general if they
can't you know control their medium well
enough to sell it effectively like as a
track it's extremely good because the
patron can't dictate what the artist
does now there's so many little patrons
that the artist still has autonomy yeah
which is this shows i do think we might
see a shift into and uh we're seeing
we're seeing the attention economy
expand right so we had with the
manufacturing economy people talked
about will a service economy work where
people are providing services we got we
got to manufacture stuff now we're in
the attention economy where people make
a living by just getting your attention
now that's scary because people then
make crazy content and crazy videos to
try and get your attention to make money
off of it so we're in that influence
space i think we're going to move into
a creator economy
so
influence i think can only go so far
once everyone has a certain degree of
influence and then i think what we're
seeing with this art what we're seeing
with youtube and tik tok is a creator
based economy where
instead of manufacturing things you're
going to make
art you're going to make entertainment
you're going to make
ideas or something i think computer code
is an example of that it's a type of art
that translates into a functional object
i wonder though i mean oh no by all
means go ahead no no go ahead
i i just want to piggyback on what i'm
saying here and ask a question you sort
of mention a shifting into a creator
economy but i wonder if our economy is
is going to i mean how long is it going
to take for it to recover to the point
where that continues to really be
pragmatic because if we really start to
struggle for resources i don't know how
we'd be able to support that
i mean you could look far ahead into
like 3d printing food and 3d printing
oil and water like um 3d printing oil
yeah if you have enough uh electricity
you could convert plastic into oil um if
you have enough carbon if you have any
materials you're talking about molecular
printing and atomic printing and stuff
they've they've worked on molecular
printing for medicine thus far but i
imagine we'll head towards atomic
printing but i mean that's that just
comes out of the energy source are they
going to let us use fusion are they
going to keep acting like it doesn't
exist i don't know
i guess i'm more optimistic now that i
think about it you know and my
investments match that right like i'm
betting on the
you know the general strength of the
american economy that's how i invested
that's how i'm betting i'm not saying a
creator based economy is going to be a
bad thing
you know
and so what i mean by that is it will be
very similar to an influence economy but
it'll be people making art and then just
selling it and you're not going to need
amazon you know you don't need to go to
stores anymore nobody needs to work at
mcdonald's we've got kiosks all of those
jobs are going away so the service jobs
are being automated people are gonna
have to find other things that people
want to exchange for and i think it's
gonna be
someone was gonna write a song they're
gonna make a piece of art they're gonna
create things and then that's gonna be
how they sell it or they post it or nft
or something like that and there will be
a way in which people can can acquire
resources in a new kind of economy in
the future art is the new currency or
one of the new currencies it's like the
old seashells they used to find and give
to their wives ten thousand hundred
thousand years ago you know these are
the new seashells these art pieces
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you